¿Cuántos retos tiene por delante la unión?
Muchísimos, pero quizá el más importante
Sean las elecciones que se van a celebrar
entre 06 y 09 de junio.
Hasta entonces,
hasta el momento en el que los ciudadanos
estén convocados a las urnas,
el bloque comunitario tiene muchos retos que afrontar.
A la invasión rusa de Ucrania se añade
el debate sobre la ampliación,
cómo salir de otra crisis económica a la que parece
que ya estamos acostumbrados,
cómo invertir en defensa
o incluso cómo abordar las políticas climáticas
tan importantes en ese paraguas llamado
pacto Verde europeo.
Desde luego,
en 2 024 con la Unión Europea no nos vamos a aburrir